(crowd bustling)
(prayer chants)
- [Announcer] So this next group,
Jamaican-born, but they came up in the UK,
spoken word artists, hip-hop artists,
and Muslim sisters.
Put your hands together
for Poetic Pilgrimage!
(crowd applauding)
- [Muneera] How you guys doin'?
Sometimes when people
see us come on stage,
they're like, "Hold on,
what's happening here?"
(beat music playing)
♫ Unlikely the MCs
♫ Yeah
♫ Unlikely the Mcs
♫ Unlikely MC
- We're connected to two
very misunderstood realities,
one being hip-hop and one being Islam.
And I think for us, as Poetic Pilgrimage,
even though we didn't set out to be
this bridge between any two communities,
in a way, I think we kind of are.
- So many people have inaccurate ideas
of what being a Muslim is
and what being a Muslim woman is about.
So we need to express ourselves,
because if we don't, then
other people will speak for us.
- [Sukina] It is important
for Muslim women's voices
to be heard because we
are so often spoken about.
Our relationship with hip-hop
is the genesis of hip-hop.
It's like giving that voice
to the people that were voiceless.
It's about, representing
the underrepresented.
It's important for Muslim
women to be present,
in places that we don't expect it to be
because I think that's
where change happens.
♫ This ain't a gimmick
♫ Or a new invention
♫ Spitting pause like stars
♫ Before I draw my pension
- [Sukina] With Poetic Pilgrimage
we strive to change our
world and our reality
in hopes that it will have
a ripple effect in changing
how the wider community view
women Muslims, black women.
We're just trying to be
an embodiment of that
in hopes that it will change the world.
♫ My soul's emotion
♫ When I cry I'm hopin'
♫ Don't we know it
♫ Lookin' for another
♫ Reason why to be
♫ A Black Josephine
♫ Together we can
♫ Pull a team
♫ What ya'll might be
♫ Like a jazz scene
♫ Either way I'm rhymin'